i want to talk about indian matchmaking
i love did you watch it with her
i don't know much about it please inform
me well maybe if you spend some time
with kaleila at night all right you know
what
all right okay i you know what you guys
could have some shared interest oh okay
christine okay rebuttal can i have a
robot defensive
cuddly baby i love to cuddle i'm a
cuddler too come on over
and i beg tom's not a cuddler but can
you please
all i want is for you to spoon me for 15
years i beg
beg and i force him to do it i'm hot i'm
hot
i'm like okay
this is what i want to say okay
during this pandemic yeah there's not
much to do
right a lot of dreams are on hold
right we are very a very mindful
household
should we have not gone to the grocery
store one time no
that's reasonable okay we haven't done
anything so her and i
are together in this house together
right right 24 7.
all right i have a video game addiction
i already told you
but secondly at nights my brother if you
know my brother steve
my brother steve doesn't wake up until
what time you think
8 p.m oh wow what yeah nocturnal now
he's a vampire
right so he'll wake up at 8pm drink two
red bulls and he's ready to go
i haven't seen him physically okay
that's your choice though you can
okay i just okay all right so then
at nights we play war zone together
right so he's i can hear him we talk
about our days
right we giggle laugh it's almost as if
we're calling each other
but we play for hours oh my god oh my
god what she's doing the technique like
i would be
so upset i i'm
so bad would you be so would you be so
dry my [ __ ]
would be so dry
oh my god what are you doing right now
like i put elmer's glue in it like all
right
well then what do you want me to do then
i would do it then
well do you guys okay how often do you
do your how often do you interact with
each other
truly throughout the day like meaningful
interest well now i
have to basically force him into
our nights together because that's the
one thing that we've talked about in
therapy i don't care that we're
that i don't see you during the day but
i love a good wine down yeah with my
that's all i want and a partner is
someone to end my day with
i agreed why else are you you in it yeah
so maybe maybe you go to bed classic
rebuttal
yep come on go keep going maybe could
you set some time aside for kaleidos
maybe have a nice meal together you
drink your wine she goes to bed before
you ellie tv show's over here
[Laughter]
listen relax guys relax i'm not falling
for this [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] okay
it's [ __ ] i had you [ __ ] none of
you guys are defending me by the way
right
right you play the game as well you
don't want anyone to have like a dry
[ __ ]
yeah i'll [ __ ] you all right now listen
all right
let's go back to indian summer go ahead
indian summer time tell me about the
show was it fun what about kissing booth
too
have you watched that one i haven't but
i heard it was better than kissing booth
the first one wow i love him i saw him
at um
mendocino farms really my niece united
because she's obsessed with
what doesn't mean what is the show for
people it's not a show it's a teenage
movie